in the meantime cases in children have
surged over the last month from around
38 000 at the end of july more than 180
thousand just last week that's according
to the american academy of pediatrics in
mississippi the governor's called about
a thousand has called in rather about a
thousand extra health care workers to
reinforce 61 short staffed hospitals
mark straussman is in jackson with more
on the story mark good morning to you
this is very troubling
very troubling gail good morning to you
this is saint dominic's hospital in
jackson clobbered by kova the last five
weeks all 64 icu beds are full more than
half by covet patients this week they're
setting up the tent you see behind me to
screen and test overflow patients for
the virus but one of the most worrisome
trends throughout this state is the
delta variance impact on kids
three weeks into mississippi school year
kovit's toll on kids is staggering
almost 12 000 students have tested
positive with nearly twenty nine
thousand now quarantined sadder still
michaela robinson's coveted story that
was my my only daughter my only child
justin waddell is michaela's father the
thirteen-year-old eighth grader started
feeling sick on wednesday august 11th
she died from covid that saturday we
never seen anything happen like this in
three days it was a shock to everybody
the whole family in mississippi barely
one of every three people has been fully
vaccinated the country's second lowest
state rate i have no intention of
issuing a vaccine mandate
period governor tate reads also opposes
mask mandates even in schools despite a
coveted surge that has alarmed many
parents and doctors pediatrician dr
anita henderson works at the hattiesburg
clinic she describes kova's impact on
kids here as a freight train and what i
mean by by a freight train is our
clinics are overrun and what would you
say to people who say ah they're young
they'll be fine we're seeing that in our
pediatric population kids who can't play
the flute anymore kids who can't
participate in sports anymore and that's
heartbreaking worrisome to henderson
more than half of the state's 82
counties have no pediatricians
little shelby davian got lucky she spent
nearly two weeks in the icu after
developing multi-infection syndrome for
children a rare but dangerous condition
that can appear after a covet 19
infection the staff told us
she's a miracle
that she was that sick and that she was
one of the worst they had seen
this hospital is among those getting the
governor's reinforcements 20 paramedics
could show up as soon as today to help
screen and test covet patients but what
this hospital could use like all
hospitals throughout this state is a
break from this viral siege
anthony yeah as dr henderson said kovatt
is a freight train thank you mark